this morning in our 2020 election
coverage we focus on pennsylvania one of
the most hotly contested states
president trump returns there tonight
democratic nominee joe biden
makes his next visit on thursday with
seven weeks left in the campaign
voting in pennsylvania is still
unsettled we don't know what the ballot
will look like
due to a court challenge and requests to
vote by
mail are soaring because of the
coronavirus
chief washington correspondent major
garrett went to one
important county major what did you find
well good morning anthony bucks county
outside of philadelphia is by population
the fourth largest in pennsylvania and
like the rest of the state it is bracing
for a massive increase in mail-in
ballots
it's hiring more staff and buying more
machines but
it needs something else
doylestown the quiet and quaint county
seat of bucks county
inside its election warehouse voting
equipment for all 304 precincts
stretches
wall to wall but all those machines
won't get as much use as usual this year
because fewer people will vote in person
and more will participate by mail it's a
different world for everybody
bob harvey chairs the bucks county board
of elections charged with making
election 2020 work
amid a pandemic we expected there to be
more
you know mail on ballot applications and
but we didn't expect these numbers
and obviously the pandemic ramped
everything up in 2016 the county had
about 20
000 requests for absentee ballots this
year it is expecting at least 200
000 possibly 250 000 are you prepared to
process that many mail-in
ballots if they all come in the
challenging part is going to be dealing
with you know counting them as quickly
as we can so bucks county is increasing
its election staff from 10 to 25.
these are the scanners it had four
scanners to count absentee ballots
now it has ten and it is refurbishing
this
office to make room for staff and
machinery this will be
absentee and mail and ballot central tom
freitag is elections director
there's going to be high-speed scanners
over here we have 10 of them
to be able to scan the ballots quickly
bucks county bought its new tabulation
equipment from clear ballot a company
specializing in vote by mail
technology we've actually increased
our customer base by 35 percent during
the pandemic
hillary lincoln is vice president of
marketing 75 percent of our pennsylvania
counties have had to scale their
absentee
equipment so we've helped them do that
of the 13 states expected to be
competitive this fall
pennsylvania is one of four that does
not allow the processing of mail-in
ballots before
election day processing means opening
envelopes flattening ballots and
preparing them to be scanned for
counting
all that takes time basically any kind
of
relief to that that we can open any
earlier would really help us if be it
three days or three weeks
anytime would really help the
pennsylvania legislature is debating
whether to allow processing before
election day but without a change to
state law bucks county expects to be
counting mail-in ballots
after november 3rd certainly we want to
be done
before i would say within a week even
the best case scenario it's going to be
a couple of days yes
maybe maybe three yeah if this race
isn't close the delay might not matter
but
bucks county went for hillary clinton by
less than one percentage point in 2016
a competitive county in a competitive
state with oh by the way
20 electoral votes that could decide the
election
tony such an important story major thank
you very much guys it's not only
pennsylvania it's michigan
it's wisconsin uh you know we should
prepare viewers right now for the fact
that they are not likely to get a result
on election night this election night
might end up being election week yeah
really and that does not mean it's not a
legit election that's what people we're
so used to knowing that night but you're
right tony i doubt very seriously we're
going to know
it's going to be a process yes it's
going to be a journey you need patience
patience yeah absolutely